Brittany here is nowadays very much a
part of France it formally joined it in
1547 having been independent for roughly
the previous 600 years but given that
Britney's neighbor was much larger far
more powerful and shared its only land
border how did Brittany manage to hold
out for so long why didn't France take
Brittany centuries earlier to begin as
of the mid 8th Century Brittany was
divided into numerous small states the
Frankish Kingdom next door realized that
Conquering the britons there would be
tough and so instead they appointed one
of the Region's rulers to collect
tribute from the rest on their behalf
this Arrangement didn't last too long
because several decades later Vikings
the raiding along the Frankish Empire's
Coast meant that its attention was
needed elsewhere and so Brittany was
free to Rebel they saw it gained some
freedom for a short time because like
everybody else in northern Europe They
too had to deal with the Vikings like
many other small states Brittany wasn't
able to resist and found itself ruled by
Norseman until the mid 9th century this
was when the grandson of the last
independent Breton ruler Alan was aided
by King ethelstan of England in
reconquering Brittany he was successful
and thus became a Duke with Brittany
becoming independent in the century
after this Brittany was a mess of
rebellions and despite its weakened
State France never invaded and the
reason why was that the French Nobles
his lands neighbor Brittany intermarried
with Brittany's Rebels and laws which
made intervention a problem
unsurprisingly it wasn't long until the
rulers of Brittany were soon dealing
with the kings of France personally who
were very interested in keeping the
duchy in line their opponents at this
time were of course the Kings of England
and both Royal houses competed for the
duchy's friendship and it was this
competition that gave the duchy a much
greater degree of Independence than it
could have hoped for normally Brittany's
position meant that it was valuable for
England to open up another front in a
war against France if it needed to and
for France robbing England of that
ability was worth giving any loyal Duke
some extra freedoms and after England
lost the Hundred Years War the only
major state with a stake in Brittany was
France which didn't make any plans to
invade or reduce the duchy's freedoms so
why well first of all France was broken
exhausted and so launching an Expedition
which would cost money and also leave it
open to attack from Spain or the Holy
Roman Empire was a No-No and at this
point if he couldn't conquer a land
there was always plan B wait for the
ruler to only have a daughter and marry
her which is what happened in 1498 when
Duke Francis II died leaving only his
daughter and to rule the duchy to
protect the duchy from France it was
agreed that Anne would marry the heir to
the Holy Roman Empire Maximilian Von
Habsburg it couldn't be done in person
because travel had its risks and so it
was done remotely this annoyed the king
of France Charles VII because he didn't
want Brittany being ruled by his rival
next door and so we politely asked for
it to be annulled by which I mean he
invaded after defeating the bretons
Charles forstand to marry him and sent
her to Paris and using his own nobles to
run Brittany instead the two didn't have
any heirs and so when Charles VII opted
to spend some time in the afterlife and
returned to Brittany for like five
minutes because Charles's successor and
cousin Louis XII at the same quarrel
with an independent Brittany and so Anne
was forced to marry again this time they
did have children and the eldest Claude
was married to the next king of France
France is the first whose son Henry
would go in to inherit both the duchy of
Brittany and the kingdom of France at
which point the title of Duke of
Brittany was abolished in the lands
thereafter were simply ruled by the king
of France thereby ending Brittany
600-year streak of Independence against
France's wishes I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bissonnette Kelly
moneymaker call show wolf Sky Chappelle
kotoitska Alex Schwinn Jerry Lambton
Jordan Longley Adams daughter rod D
Martin Marcus arsner a firefly Y and
hockey Captain psydog Spencer Lightfoot
Miss izet boogly Wiggly Marvin Casa
Winston caywood Daniel to be in
communion Aaron the white Gustav Swan
the mcwhopper words about books podcast
she went in spinning three plates Maggie
baskowski Anthony Beckett Coppertone and
Charles the first